indrasena brazil's largest favela
volunteers distribute donations of soap
and disinfectant to people in need
Brazil has the highest number of cases
and deaths attributed to kovat 19 five
people live in fernando de Sousa's house
and she's worried the majority as
seniors who work and get paid by the day
so we hope we can get help in the
absence of stronger government measures
in some slums local armed gangs are
reportedly imposing lock downs to slow
the spread of the Pandy mia in group
wakes for people who die of coronavirus
have been banned and bodies must be
cremated within 24 hours with a favor by
a hotline for emergency services can't
cope with inquiries and requests
prompting the president to threaten
sanctions against those who call foreign
justified reasons we used to get three
thousand calls a day now it's 80
thousand we can only process half that
number in libri chile which has the
second highest number of confirmed cases
in the region the government is rushing
to prepare 4,500 beds for critical cases
the peak of this pandemic here in Chile
is estimated to be about a month away
which means that there's no time to lose
to prepare for the worst
but as the experience of wealthier
countries has demonstrated it takes much
more than additional beds to lower the
curve of contagion which is vital to
prevent the collapse of the public
health system although it's increasing
mass testing is still not widespread in
most countries which is why
epidemiologists believe the real number
of infected people in Latin America
could be at least 10 times the confirmed
number the presidents of Mexico and
Brazil the region's most populous
countries are still refusing to impose
even partial quarantine back in Chile
authorities are ordering quarantines in
neighborhoods or cities on a strictly
need to basis not nationwide according
to the who've remaining healthy also
includes being
able to work and see your family
obviously the longer you were locked up
the more that two impacts your health
that's what epidemiologists are also
evaluating it's a calculation but one
that many in countries that haven't
ordered the lock downs fear could end up
costing unnecessary lives you see a
Newman al-jazeera Santiago